how's it going rez nice pad welcome to
volgarr the Viking I would assume some
Swedish people made this I'm just who
knows it supposed to be difficult and
I'm not much for difficult games but I'm
gonna try it anyway alright
oh hell yeah
yeah badass slap that chest [ __ ] yeah
oh hell hey this is a regular day in
Sweden oh there we got double jump that
[ __ ] penetrate the wall holy cow how do
I get how do i goddamn I'm a genius
hot chop that's rad
ha ha ha thomas rap that's right
that slap that dick with a stick hi I'm
pretty good at this what's up pretty
easy
this game's easy a lot of them other
blood looks like it's made in paint
oh no dope how did I block I don't even
know how I did that [ __ ] my god I'm a
natural Viking huh don't touch me
oh that back block shields gots my back
I haven't even been touched
oh [ __ ] don't touch me don't touch me
don't touch me don't you I don't even
know what's going on oh wow I piss now
my piss now I'm pissed now how do I
touch it
what
Oh sweets angry now so how do I block I
don't know how to block easy skim is
easy just like my mom no she's the
wonderful lady
god damn it game what the [ __ ] that's
fine no big deal
that's fine I have to restart everything
who cares
I don't whoa whoa badass
what's up [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] [ __ ]
my guy this games so easy so easy oh
damn no McDonald's McDonald's Oh Mike
Donald's head up on chop that spear up
in these days chop chop chop chop chop
chop - chop chop chop chop how do I kill
that thing
nope how do i oh oh oh oh oh I'm sorry
what
no why back here what do you want from
me game you serious what happens down
here then no I not okay fine oh come on
oh come just call that a jump how is
that a jump in which vocabulary is that
a jump met he does that [ __ ] thing
where he's like hey I'm gonna bump my
head in this dick there we go
there we go you guys want piece of me
all right oh man whoa whoa sup boys stop
jumping stop ha ha ha ha ha ha a shield
I lost a shield just go in there Aloha
my my beer jiggles that's [ __ ] high a
challenger appears slices dick off
Swedish castration famous [ __ ] Yolo
nailed it [ __ ]
this is for my own dad this is for my
jiggly beard
this is for my Tatas this is for my
brothers come
Piper too much stop everything but but
rap rap name and dude in jävla fan
there's to be a checkpoint why say no
checkpoint how you like Dex meter let me
know I don't don't do sweet dish power
mutha [ __ ] Bam Bam Shazam
Sam and it slam [ __ ] robot it off
remote f not did love Bala when you
can't move midair magia they door I only
have nothing I only have nothing really
pills to no checkpoints in this game
don't shoot at me praise yeah great
never mind that [ __ ] met Jeff ha ha
no no no it's a it's a it's fine you
know what it's fine
my name's Jeb la Fitte commit we have
the she'll of awesome Navarez
what is the plan Oprah Oprah Oprah Oprah
hmm
yes chop-chop nothing can stop me I'm a
Swedish Viking ah except those [ __ ]
thanks god dammit why is it that not a
Czech boy Jack fight okay we never came
this far we never came this far go for
night Yolo
yo God as fine really slap daddy all on
the flo slap that give me some more
slack dad till yogurt sauce laughter Oh
badass mode activate you guys want to
skate too bad Vikings don't skate they
eat them the skateboards I mean all
right come here look at this [ __ ] BAM
hey how's it going down here guys chop
flap flap I have a shield what's up
that's what's up that's what's up in my
but nothing is up in my butt all right
medic whoo boy get it hey Steve doll
[ __ ] Snoop Dogg what's it said he does I
gotta say that even though like the
jumping is weird as [ __ ] it's a it's a
smooth gameplay doodling a lot cute
commit though mastered a neigh-neigh
idiot yeah nah Sariah dama charger math
sphere like Britney mother [ __ ] us okay
lock the I'm sick day insanity edit ad
how did I become a worse at a game you
think you become better after a while
but no not me
checkpoints [ __ ] have you heard
of it that's how we do it in to peel it
back down free beer and [ __ ] best
town in the world I'm a charging brick
NIC on my charge and Britney it's
Britney [ __ ] Yolo uh-oh
oh my god what do I do now help me
Brittany come on oh my god oh my god I'm
alive what do you want
that's right that's right rocking powers
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what are you doing them Viking Scosche
how how much miss get that 100 I come on
I don't like this idiot nice
Oh Harris you bet dick that's how you
can do it
see whoa whoa whoa by the power of
Grayskull ha ha ha what not it whoa
I'm not losing whatever not nothing hi
my let him [ __ ] me that's how you do it
you let him [ __ ] you that's how you get
places in life come on [ __ ] me say
that's how you do it
oh ah ah you idiot I'm not ready
climbing up ah ah fine oh [ __ ]
what is that only got ha is that all you
got
it's not only gotta cut for damn look
I don't have it even II don't don't lure
it into that all right here we go
chop-chop
whoa is that a checkpoint I'm the main
I'm the main main the [ __ ] off right in
the ass
that's how we do it no we don't we don't
do that normally it's it this is a trap
oh my god it is there we go
easy peasy lemon dick I mean squeezy
okay oh [ __ ] there's more like Oh
oh [ __ ] all right I gotta get it through
that hole that's what she said nailed it
how do I do it now all right easy easy
this game is so easy I don't see how
anyone can all shut chut chut chut No
hold it edu
oh all right we're safe here no oh man
Yolo Oh
Yolo never works kids oh all right I
don't get this one are you idiot what if
here do me BAE what do you hear
yep I'm not not doing anything Matt what
am I supposed to do here
oh well take me in the ass take me
thanks
cha-cha-cha cha-cha-cha tap tap no ha ha
ha ha
oh not not bad rap blast fun way oh all
right here we go oh oh oh oh okay
what a fine oh [ __ ] okay just think
yours the other Blaine pills
oh it's it's a shield mine got on my
genius
don't you die shoot my shoes that
[ __ ] prada [ __ ] okay what you gonna
do here is that all you got
oh shut hope you really enjoy this video
leave a like if you did hits the sky
come forth today I'll set some buds of
the bow out of here
I don't wanna piss quest plate clash
I'll go at it oh but I said I'm gonna do
anything I don't know anything I do it